that tub o is the ultimate shot I call
this Snorlax crotch that is a snore line
up your shot if I ever saw one that rude
you ever wonder what a snorlax couch
looks like wine or no more no more
already we have some comments are saying
that the player character kind of looks
like me hey does we're gonna have to
reassess that oh oh like a what is that
rolling Boulder Evie Evie my Kangaskhan
kangaskhan is a pretty good name for a
cat come on hey kangaskhan quick tea
bagging those flowers and give me a good
shot that is where Kangas cons go to do
their bids 0 it is a pokeball I was
gonna tack whoa Oh action shot action
shot of me out trying to eat the
unhatched children of piggy Oh No ah I
had more shot your vibe pictures of
Pikachu I think that's but look closing
his eyes that's a good one Pikachu and
during a fugue state what the [ __ ]
that's surfboard Oman the water type
non-canonical I feel like I should use
the the later one of me out where he's
like being murdered yeah always been
knocked to the ground yeah this is it
here is a dead meow outside oh you're
gonna get rated on size 310 is only
so-so what is Professor Oak's scale this
is 310 out of a million strokes
transparency is really not 7 750 is so
so 800 points alright see I think 800 is
when it stops being so so and getting to
all right yeah and that's when you get
to all right yeah but Professor oh he
doesn't share a lot of like generous
feelings with people he plays it pretty
cold yeah cuz he doesn't want you to get
too uppity you were close but you see it
disappoint Boak about it be photographed
from behind note to self Pokemon don't
like butt shots Professor Oak is not a
poke a ass man I took so many pictures
and I regret it already read everything
about it alright let's see it I'll save
the results of today's trip in the
bookman report wait jerk let's return to
the lamb
Electabuzz electabuzz I'll take got
forgot forgot restrain yourself
Electabuzz trying to get into the
research facility oh do you want me to
take pictures of your dumb cat but
apparently yeah look at that hot diglett
action if you ever want to suffer
emotional trauma I recommend doing a
google image search for diglett with
safesearch off let's just say many
people have been interpreted him as a
penis I mean you gotta get some I got to
get some points right and at least his
butt is roughly in the middle of the
frame there I learned about Pokemon a
lot when I that's cool because oh that's
why he got into a career in Pokemon
education I think maybe Professor Oak
has gotten a little too close over the
years and that's why he's got that crazy
in his eyes I'm gonna hit yes that
you're just gonna hit the only but then
use this apple shape Pokemon yeah so
known as Apple brush a to do it I bet he
says that to the Pokemon before he has
sex with them I think it's gonna turn
what up it's coming over here for
getting very anxious oh yeah down and
look at those hot pics hot take the pics
I I respect pokemons even though i don't
like you're a dumbass great knowledge of
them uh I'm just like I'm going to town
on his junk but he's just still sleeping
yeah sucking me out oh man yeah what if
I threw one over here so that he comes
to eat it got a beam him
yeah just make it rain there oh yeah oh
yeah they're nice that's the only that
is beautiful beautiful surfing pikachu
yeah oh yeah 300 points that could be
better so so I suppose this is very
lively sly value staff as the technique
double double BAM well done this angry
shot is pretty cool thousand right in
the middle well booboo for that I went
from 430 to 4,000 really where's giving
her a bunch of them oh I'm not even okay
there we go they might come back down
yeah oh he's so sad oh sad town he's so
sad I told you the kikuna or coming back
down her away to beam sore throat being
intro does all I know how to do all
right yeah that's not gonna be better
than surfing if you could shoot i
guarantee you that hey i like to take
your what are you doing face eat it like
the bus you still got all he's coming at
you oh I'll get the TV get the TV
picture it doesn't matter it always give
me a hint telling you to throw an apple
at that thing for the right look to the
right beam him hurry Serena
yeah hidden path oh yeah boo boo Boop oh
now it can stop it can't stop when I
want to take a good picture Chris why
are you looking at it so fondly I'm so
shocked what oh she's thinking fly it's
gonna be way better yeah you ready for
this we're gonna some big improvement
here folks oh yeah double leg time Big
Time lament yeah oh it's volcano time
you ready to meet some [ __ ]
charmanders cuz we're about to it's
never gonna be the perfect run on the
first go Chris get it get a single shot
on hole pics oh she sure as hell yeah
that was nice get off the track alright
now throw those thing into the lava all
right now you go into the lava yah bonk
bonk oh did I hit it I think I hit it
get away turn to the left no you're
derailed by po fixes this is hugging it
this this isn't good get out of the way
it's real I'm gonna be some mangled
vulpix wreckage on this track a picture
of magmar lookin a hell of dumb come on
over here magmar you dumb piece of [ __ ]
oh yeah be angry yet a Charizard he's a
Charmander sorry get it together Christ
was gonna need you to not embarrass
yourself any more on this too late whoo
here we go this is gonna be good what's
happening huh Moltres
no unless when I'm around oh now you
presented yet knowing you as but you
know that Oh ain't down with that come
on quit representing us get over here
that's some good char mandarin oh look
at that they are yelling like crazy in
the back I only got 90 whoa whoa holy
Charmander yeah party I just interrupted
a Charmander swinger parties what I did
it the charred thingy o million yeah
you're right there was a charmeleon roll
with some lava oh nice he's gonna come
all the chosen yeah get it no oh no oh
no the charizard was right there I ran
out of [ __ ] [ __ ] you film camera I think
the right side this side yeah this
awkwardly frame shot it don't think he's
gonna notice that the face is cut off
that was the size sizes pretty good ok
he's gonna he's gonna like it like says
he doesn't know that he's [ __ ]
totally not can't see right it's looking
dumb as hell hmm stop and stop abusing
them and take more pictures I don't oh
there is Psyduck he's coming back around
get a better shot get the thing get that
get that a horrible thing that always
abomination of nature yeah get that all
dead oh oh that yeah mollusk that was a
good shot you know what if you're not on
a surfboard you can just GTFO Pikachu
thirdly Shia worst shot of the day 30
points cuz Bulbasaur only had his bulb
he's like the tip of his bulb exposed
from downtown
oh whoa or figure out your man oh look
at that oh my goodness you just owe you
mainly just involved you made a big
mistake more than fighting this looks
lewd wow yeah wow you ever seen a
picture of a mag mark given a charmeleon
a low chipper come on you got throw up
the hill right and then they'll know
they're coming down come on guys over
here this way let's go Charmander party
huh what's just everyone bunk get charm
guys oh my goodness yeah oh this is
gonna turn around though too many butts
for this oak is so mad yeah they're all
look in your direction all right you're
good we're good we don't want to blow it
on the charizard pic later we are gonna
get this there we go nice Moltres come
back Moltres I'll come back involve it
yeah yeah evolved into mole Quatro
Quatro magmar you are a real piece of
[ __ ] type Pokemon I'm not gonna lie to
you you're cool all right here we go I
got 19 shots left for this Charmeleon
what get is gonna go carp all right get
it bak yeah all here it is nice okay
he's gonna blow fire your face yeah yeah
oh it's so good yeah spew that flame
show them the humping one I think he'll
really enjoy that no yeah yeah yeah that
one resolve in bag Mars dome yeah that's
a good one all right there's gonna be
some good Charmander ones here I think
this is probably the winner yeah there
no buts and as we cuz we all as we all
know locates butts I think this is the
way yeah that's pretty good oh and it's
got a good amount of screen tearing in
it too that's perfect what do you think
of that mag mar all right I need
Professor Oak I need you to appreciate
the context of this photo there's a
dramatic pose happening mag Mars being
assaulted by this Charmeleon or
alternatively or alter we're watching
some
cross-species contact pose the pose got
better points code of course yeah yeah
cuz he's getting blasted by that truck
million hey he really is yeah he gives
you points oh and may just want / just
piss you weren't closer to it yeah
that's true all right oh I'm definitely
gonna save this one yeah but it's not as
good it's definitely not as good does
heat slamming you on the sides whoa x 6
that if how for photo yeah there are
other Charmander char manders plural you
can pluralize it it's okay you can do
that Wow still not as good Wow oak you
are inscrutable this will make hidden
Pokemon come out into the open it's the
pester ball yeah just go ahead into the
pokemons natural habitat litter it with
these balls that annoy the [ __ ] out of
them and then take photos damn it oak
classic Oh